let's do this
let's talk about how to control your
mind i got here a clip from joe rogan oh
yeah joe posted so uh there's two videos
playing side by side top top and bottom
on the top is cnn's version broadcast
version of joe rogan's announcement that
he was being treated for covet on the
bottom is joe's actual video for those
that can't see this is insane cnn
altered the colors to make joe rogan
look grayish green sick it's crazy let
me i'm gonna play a little bit okay okay
i guess you can't hear it oh here we go
din z pack
uh
the sun well you get the point
uh
so in it look
see uh it's hard it's hard to it's hard
to describe this for people who are
listening other than
they altered the colors of joe rogan's
skin to make him look like he's dying
yeah they make him look like a
frankenstein green potato
like literally rotting green potato joe
just just posted the clip and he put
yellow journalism fake news
here's what you guys need to understand
about this
someone at cnn
and probably more than one person
probably someone with some authority
said we are going to edit this footage
make joe look very sick
we're they're not going to get any extra
views by making joe look sick
no people aren't going to be like hey
everybody watch this video of joe rogan
no no no
what they're doing is the people who
watch cnn will just see a very sickly
looking joe rogan
all they're really doing it's not about
ratings this is cnn in my opinion
deliberately trying to manipulate the
narrative to mind control to brainwash
to propagandize absolutely i mean this
is the same time they were making the
arguments that joe rogan was taking
horse medicine and of course was dealing
with covid in a way which they clearly
presented him not dealing with in a good
way meanwhile in the video he's like hey
you know i just got covered a couple
days ago i'm feeling better than ever i
took this and this and this and this i
threw the kitchen sink at it so so their
narrative was very important to upkeep
one of the ways that they kept this
narrative is by faking this video by by
lying to the american people to portray
it as if he wasn't doing well which is
absolutely ridiculous you need you need
to go to joe rogan's instagram if you
can't see this because you're listening
on the podcast you need to see this
because your jaw will hit the floor
they make him look like he's got like a
lupus
or liver cancer super like pale white
light and dark shadow yeah this is why
cnn is the enemy of humanity i mean this
is it and and this was their reaction to
it along with other corporate media
representatives that were mad that he
got better he was able to improve his
health and so was dana wright so is
aaron rodgers and so are a lot of people
including congressmen and women that
take the same treatment as he does the
treatment that they're trying to of
course say doesn't exist doesn't work
and it's and it's based on horses that's
ridiculous and criminal regardless of
that if you go to your doctor and your
doctor says they have a they have a
recommendation or prescription why is
cnn telling people not to do that yeah
why it's it's sponsored by
pfizer exactly is that why i've i've
seen people who have had liver failure
and what so so uh lupus makes you turn
yellow right uh no so lupus is not the
one that makes jaundice it's jaundice
and yeah that is caused by liver failure
yes yeah so they uh they make them look
like what's the what's the what's the
skin cancer like what what's what's the
cancer that makes you turn green you
know what i'm talking about no gangrene
no no there's a there's a cancer that
affects an organ that makes your skin
start pigmenting green
like it looks like he is dying
they cnn made this they want people to
see this and be like wow yeah this looks
like getting out of head on the story
they're like oh we got to get ahead on
this one let's see they didn't look bad
they did it to trump they made them
orange remember that photo where they
made his face super bright orange and it
was just like his hair was blowing back
yeah yeah let me see if i can pull that
one up what were you going to say i was
going to say this actually looks to me
like they're trying to make it look like
he has too much silver in his system
because silver actually makes people
turn blue but i was going to say i did
see a tweet earlier today from a lady
who said oh my gosh look at joe rogan he
looks so gray and sick i can't believe
that he was actually saying that he's
healthy and i'm like it worked on at
least one person
oh my gosh yeah they totally altered
this picture
i researched that blue silver skin guy
it turned out he was rubbing silver on
his face
that he was making at his house so it
wasn't being done properly apparently no
so there was a family somewhere in the
deep south that was taking too much
colloidal silver and it starts to show
in your skin because your body can't
excrete it because it's metal you're not
supposed to did you see the guy who's
fully blue he looks like a smurf i
haven't seen him but i did see a picture
of like the whole family so there's like
a whole bunch of them who are obviously
doing something you gotta look up the
blue skinned silver guy it's pure blue
it's like dark dark dark and he had been
rubbing it on himself which is why
that'll do it but he didn't tell people
that at first so he caused a panic about
wow freaking out small doses of
colloidal silver which have
antimicrobial properties yeah maybe
maybe just a little yeah
that's why they made silverware it's
because the it would be really good for
your immune system to put it in your
mouth huh interesting stuff about all
that
that's my so we we do i do have the
image whereas trump and even snopes is
like this twitter account white house
photos is not connected to what do they
say uh twitter is not connected with or
controlled by the white house itself its
actions do not represent or reflect
white house interests or policies
and they had this like look trump does
have a spray tan it's true sure yeah but
they would they would you'd see them on
tv on cnn and um and it's just like they
saturate his face to make it look bright
orange
and then when you see him you're like
when you see him and act in real life
you're like oh yeah he does have a spray
tan but it's not that crazy
that's it it's it's
in the movie don't look up
they show the right as being the people
chanting don't look up
the right-wing politicians are like
don't look up those aren't familiar it's
about a comet's gonna hit the earth and
kill everybody and so the republicans
and the right wing are like ain't no
comet i'm not gonna look up because if
you look up you see it right and i'm
like yo that's brian stelter not the
right the right is going debate me
why won't aoc debate me that's what the
right is doing the right is demanding
you come and discuss these ideas
it's cnn that's saying don't look at the
news anywhere else
yeah absolutely it's it's
just when you think you can't get any
more absurd we have this and and this is
an old story joe rogan of course just
posted this on his instagram just a
couple moments ago but this happened a
long time ago so um we have to
understand that this is what the
corporate media does they they lie
they're professional liars i think they
there's a lot of sociopaths within them
that obviously do the bidding of the
special interests and whether it was the
banker bailouts whether it was the
weapons of mass destruction in iraq we
have to understand especially if you're
a youtube moderator you should really
consider the harm
the real life consequences and harm that
the corporate media has caused so many
innocent countless numbers of
individuals that had their life ruined
and destroyed and ended because of the
corporate media lies and then to
destroy something that potentially could
help people destroy this
alternative that members of congress are
being treated with that right there is
some next level criminality that needs
to be addressed right away because when
you have someone trying to knowingly lie
in a way that will hurt you
you have criminal actions being
conducted on you by criminal
institutions who will do and say
anything for a buck i just want to add
they're desperate man yes let let this
be the takeaway because joe rogan has
the biggest show in culture culture and
politics the biggest joe he gets more
than 10 times he gets like 12 or 13
times the traffic on one of his shows
that they get in prime time and they
think they're going to get away with
smearing him in this way joe puts out
one instagram post and it everybody
everybody sees it yes and it just it's
just flushing cnn is flushing themselves
down the toilet by doing this chris you
worked in a lot of media institutions
like
how would this go over if someone would
come to you being like hey we're going
to do this like what would happen
how could this happen you worked in a
lot of newsrooms i think your
perspective is valid here well
thankfully i haven't been in any kind of
corporate press institutions you know so
i can only imagine how it would go over
there um this would certainly not fly in
any place that i've worked for many
reasons but i do something i am thinking
about right now is the kind of could you
imagine being the person at cnn that is
making that call i mean can you imagine
like the sort of godlike thrill that you
have with even if you're not shaping the
narrative because obviously they're
failing they're flushing themselves down
the toilet like you said but at least
they perceive themselves to have this
god-like power of manipulating and
sculpting exactly what they think their
viewers are going to live and and
experience i mean that has to give them
some sort of uh
some sort of a sick thrill that gets
them
yeah but it's intoxicating right it has
to be yeah yeah it was a it was like a
drug as when i worked at mines for like
five years i was doing this kind of
thing deciding what was gonna get seen
and it was like i had to fight the
addictive force of it because it's like
such a powerful you're like i'm going to
decide what a million people see now i'm
going to decide what and one cheap
employee gets to do that in a moment and
then like every employee gets to take a
turn and decide and the power is so
unnecessary remember how they kept using
that same footage of italy during the
coveted pandemic
they kept taking the same clip from
italian hospital it was being aired all
over the u.s just absolutely crazy where
would we be without the internet
if we couldn't share this news rapidly
in afghanistan still for sure yeah
definitely probably syria and libya and
no joke maybe even literally like some
of us would be here because yeah we
wouldn't be able to counter that
narrative people might have signed up
believing the lies
so there is a quote that says insults
are the last resort of insecure people
with a crumbling position trying to
appear confident and i do believe that
is the case so that makes me wonder what
exactly it means when some gigantic
media conglomerate like cnn is turning
people different colors how badly have
you lost when you literally have to
fine-tune the color of someone's
recording to make them look sick and bad
and uncomfortable like
trump joe needs to like take that money
he's got
and
hire more of him yes like hire many more
joe rogans and make more podcasts and
i don't know how he does it but
and legally go after cnn i mean what are
you doing what are you waiting for i
mean they're they're they're besmirching
you they're lying about you they're
slandering you they're saying you're on
horse medicine knowingly when when they
know they're not you had one of their
co-hosts on and and you confronted him
and he admitted you were right and then
he went back on cnn and said oh no he
was wrong are you kidding me like the
slap uh in the face sorry i'm hitting
microphones here it's gonna get crazy
we're gonna get wild here get ready
you're gonna get rugged yeah i'll do it
but but the fact that they're
they can't get away with this if people
hold them accountable you could hold
them accountable in a court of law i
think it's more than enough time to do
it but this is also why internet
censorship is so important of an issue
because when we see people censored time
and time again it's not cnn that gets
hit for doing these incredulous horrible
actions it's not the real life harm that
they cause that they get held
responsible for no
it's a small independent media
organization talking to their friends
it's medical doctors talking about their
findings it's people expressing their
opinions that are getting hit and
destroyed and having their livelihoods
taken away by big tech censorship as of
course they're promoting cnn they're
they're ranking them in the algorithm
even higher so everyone sees them on the
front page it's sick and disgusting
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you